if you've played The Witcher 3
you know Geralt isn't the only hero of
the northern kingdoms sure we get to
play as ciri from time to time but
wouldn't it be nice to take control of
some of the wild hunts other ladies
thanks to a mod from an individual named
Park Han you can do just that I regret
we didn't try that earlier much the mod
available on Nexus mods allows you to
control Tris yennefer or ciri throughout
the entirety of The Witcher 3 this is
really just a reskin of garel so
whichever lady you choose will still
fight and speak like the original hero
and it runs best on version 1.1 one of
the witcher 3 steam release though you
will still run into issues with certain
armor sets and starting a new game plus
the mod might not be perfect but the
witcher 3 on the other hand is pretty
darn close GameSpot gave CD Projekt RED
masterpiece a ten out of ten and even
named it our overall game of the year
when it's blood and wine expansion
releases in 2016 you can bet your silver
sword will still be talking about it
[Music]